29 games on the season 27 starts now for
jordan lyles just under 500.
this one on the ground could be two
quarter seconds for one the relay in
time
back to the mound lyles has all kinds of
time easy lob over to first and the
inning is done lucas giolino on for his
29th start he's looking for his 10th win
as era about three and three quarters
timid short
with a long way home
close over there at third base one out
he struck him out a 3-2 change-up from
giolito this shows you the confidence
that lucas has in that change he'll
throw any count
and peters is looking for anything else
but that
and lucas gets a pop-up
he puts it in play once
continues to get on base this time he's
at second anderson one for one
3-2
swinging a miss anderson strikes out
a one-two from lyles in the swing and a
miss strike three he strikes out abreu
again with a slider and he leaves a man
at third
another opportunity now for a ranger
zitter with a runner in scoring position
0-2 pitch garcia strikes out swinging
the rangers are all for four
today with runners in scoring position
here's ron dawg
absolutely crushed the ball yasmani
grandahl smashes another baseball this
one to right it's out of here
in a heartbeat he just tattooed another
one
he is really fun to watch right now and
it's one nothing
so he is the only
sox player who's figured out how to hit
one out of here looking for
one of those crooked numbers here in the
fourth inning
into left field base hit
drawn in infield cesar hernandez hits
the jackpot and the sox have taken a
three-nothing lead so a pretty nice
inning a three spot for the sox so far
and they lead three to nothing
anyway walk has loaded him up and this
inning is becoming a bit of a mess
in the air right field garcia won't get
there
one run is home throw to the plate not
in time
ta with an exceptional slide to get
around the prospective tag of trevino
and jose does add to the total it's five
nothing so chris woodward out there and
he's gonna have to remove jordan lyle's
long difficult inning
and this one on the ground
fielded cleanly by kinder philippa and
the inning is over as he's thrown out
rangers with a couple of base runners
now as jose trevigno steps in
tim
and cesar
and a double play much needed six four
three so keiner falefa with a chance to
get that runner home he had a base hit
his last time up
and this one lined over second that is a
base hit so isaiah another multi-hit
game
it gets peters in
and it's 5-1 so they cash in
one of those big base runners
[Applause]
there's a line drive caught
by a bagnes right on the edge of the
outfield grass might as well jump
[Applause]
go ahead jump anderson two for three
today
puts this on the ground left side of the
infield
playable for yanni hernandez he's two up
two down
weinstocks did everything in one inning
today five runs on six hits in that
fourth inning and that was a very tiny
seven pitch
sixth inning
for mike fulton average so he's locked
in six up six down for him and 97
pitches will be
what lucas will throw today
a job well done
certainly got in the work that he had to
get in with only the one walk and he
leaves with a
pretty nice lead
to third that's a fair ball montana wow
what a range he played
johan monkatta right at the edge of the
diamond
berries low at first
that was a terrific play and juwan
realized he couldn't let the ball
go any further because it wasn't going
to go foul
so he picks it up in fair territory
flips it across and gets him
what terrific play
to first that's smoked and low throws
wide of second and save the call kinder
philippa
didn't get the tag down on abraham he
had a lot of time to do it
and safe at second base
well i think because jose ran
so far inside he ran on the grass inside
they might get the benefit of this ball
oh maybe not
safe yeah he did miss him on the tag
two on for garcia
leori garcia that's fair riding the rail
down the left field line and the
ricochet
takes calhoun inside out and the sox get
the speed of hamilton home
layori garcia a rope double down the
left field line and it's 7-1
so the rangers with runners at the
corners nobody out for adolesce garcia
oh that ball hit well high and deep out
to center field back to the wall for it
is hamilton and he makes the catch
tagging at third connor falefa he scores
but three outs to go mike wright's still
on the hill
strike three to solac wright has a
strikeout to start this ninth
johanna third spears this and slings it
to first and a long step was late
for peters two down
to short tim anderson
magic number to four sox win it
with a five-run inning 7-2
you